we've known for a long time that the
building of the Keystone XL and Dakota
access pipelines are terrible ideas and
yet nevertheless Donald Trump issued
executive orders to try to hurry their
construction which has been pretty
embarrassing on the world stage it also
violates agreements made by the federal
government
and the Native Americans it's also
outdated energy technology there's also
a lower and lower demand for crude
energy it would contribute to greenhouse
gas emissions the pipelines would not
really create too many permanent jobs
the way Donald Trump likes to say but
one of the biggest criticisms of the
Dakota access pipeline especially from
people living close to the pipeline
where the pipeline would be built is the
environmental impact on land and on
water in the surrounding area and in the
particular case of the Dakota access
pipeline we've recently learned that the
nearly 4 billion dollar oil pipeline
before even being completed has already
been leaking oil you've probably not
heard that it's been leaking oil in
corporate media it didn't leak a lot of
oil but it hasn't yet been completed
this is not some abstract concern about
what problems might the pipeline cause
in the future it's a reality now we
found out that last month the Dakota
access pipeline had its first spill 84
gallons of liquid petroleum into the
surrounding environment now yes 84
gallons is very very little I get that
but it's already leaking and it hasn't
even been completed yet the pipeline is
nearing completion and they've now begun
loading oil into it in preparation for
it becoming fully operational Jan hassel
Minh a lawyer for the Standing Rock
Sioux tribe who has been protesting the
pipeline's construction said quote they
keep telling everybody that it is
state-of-the-art that leaks won't happen
that nothing can go wrong it's always
been false
they haven't even turned the thing on
and it's shown to be false and of course
disclosure and honesty is kind of part
of the problem here neither the company
building the pipe
nor any government informed the public
about this spill right after it happened
so we found out about it a month later
so there are questions about
transparency when it comes to future
spills obviously the state is only
required to notify the public if there's
a spill that imminently risks Public
Health and the obvious question is well
according to whose opinion
hasil Minh also added quote it doesn't
give us any pleasure to say I told you
so
but we have said from the beginning that
it's not a matter of if but when
pipelines leak and they spill it's just
what happens Standing Rock Sioux tribe
Chairman Dave R Shambo said quote our
lawsuit challenging this dangerous
project is ongoing and it's more
important than ever for the court to
step in and halt additional accidents
before they happen not just for the
Standing Rock Sioux tribe and our
resources but for the 17 million people
whose drinking water is at risk the
United States is not even benefiting
from this pipeline we're talking about a
foreign company using our natural
resources for oil that is
disproportionately going to go and be
consumed by people in other countries
the risks clearly outweigh even the best
possible potential benefits here and I
will remind you never far behind with
Trump is a potential conflict of
interest Donald Trump was at least at
one point financially connected to the
company that owns or will own the
completed pipeline we have no real
evidence that Trump has severed those
financial ties other than some advisor
at some point saying that Donald Trump
has figured out how to stop the
conflicts of interest or whatever which
quite frankly means nothing to me I mean
it's worth basically dog crap it's of
absolutely no value to us whatsoever